today's topic um
i think this is worth covering this is a
pretty crazy story there's another
insane story we wanted to tell you about
this really really pissed me off
yesterday uh let's put this washington
post hair sheet up on the screen so
this mom uh her name is rebecca furlet
uh in chicago
she has joint custody or had joint
custody of her 11 year old son with her
ex-husband and she joined this zoom call
which was just supposed to be about like
child support and normal sort of issues
that you have between former spouses and
managing their arrangement with their
children
the judge
starts off the proceeding by asking her
whether or not she's vaccinated
she responded she wasn't explaining
she's had adverse reactions to vaccines
in the past and that a doctor had
advised her against getting inoculated
against the coronavirus saying it poses
a risk is that true or not who knows
the judge responds by stripping her of
all her custody rights
takes her son
oh
lordy lordy we like to party
we don't cause in trouble
we don't bother nobody i'm just using
that as a prayer because the usual
prayers they don't work
you know thoughts and prayers
god damn this is dumb it just goes to
show you that it's not because you're
educated that you're smart
you could be educated in having a high
powered like place and still make dumb
choices
i mean this is bananas
pretending that this is in the interest
of the child to take the child away from
their mother this is completely bananas
and if there are any other extenuating
circumstances or something listen i
leave it open that that is the case but
in terms of what the news is reporting
the uh chicago sometimes is the first
with the report and now the washington
post as well
this was really the only issue okay he
starts the hearing by saying hey are you
vaccinated she says no and he takes her
kid yeah this is
so insane and so outrageous and gets to
the the fact that you know
covid is one factor and kid safety
around the coronavirus is one factor to
be weighed in but there are a lot of
things that go into the well-being of a
child
okay
what are your thoughts i'm four and i
think that's the thing i'm four vaccines
i'm four vaccines you're vaccinated i'm
vaccinating i got back
i got my two shots that's not even
that's not even the thing
tell them i don't even have to say this
[ __ ] that i'm too vaccinated but some of
y'all gonna be like well these are
people there's no destination it's not
even that cause i'm vaccinated so i
ain't even about that but you're gonna
rip that remove the cup so you're saying
her that's what in your head you're
saying
that kid is going to be more traumatized
about her mom not being vast then you
strip and putting him in the system
that's your that's your way of thinking
you know how the system is it's like the
environment of how to where the kid is
have to be [ __ ] up for the system to
be better than whatever the parents are
offering and you're doing that just
because she decides because that's her
choice i'm not pro-vaccine i'm
pro-choice
all choices you think that that's not
gonna oh that's not gonna be arming the
kid wow
yo that's abusive power that is just oh
that's just distasteful that's just very
distasteful
not much to say this is
very dumb go ahead the boy's father
matthew is vaccinated his father his
lawyer
jeffrey leving said monday the court's
ordering
court's order reversing the august 10
decision was a mistake
so he wants to keep custody the child
whoa
okay
that's dumb [ __ ] so the judge reverses
it doesn't offer an explanation for why
he's put in place in the first place or
why he reversed it so there's no
accountability there just change your
heart because of public outcry
people's kids are taken away
unfortunately for her she had the
wherewithal to go to the public to
create public pressure although
otherwise looks like this would have
just stayed but
good lord this whole vaccine
and covet scares being overblown in some
departments if you're getting to the
point where you're taking people's kids
away because you don't like the choice
that they made to not be vaccinated
imagine what kind of damage you're doing
to that child mentally potentially
physically
right to just remove them from their
their mother god damn are we so
terrified of kobe that we think it's
sensible to remove certain people
from their parents when i was teaching
dance i was i was i work for social
services have you ever worked for social
services no sir it's not a cute place
it's not a cute place to put a child his
house has to be in a terrible state
for you to think that social services
are going to be better than where yet a
vaccine ain't it
it ain't it
this this ain't it buddy that ain't it
and you know sometimes people will be
like oh these people are just conspiracy
theorists but when you hear about
stories like these these are real
stories how does it not make you think
that the government is not willing to
overstep its bounds now this is a judge
within that state cool but there have
been other cases and other stories
around that have echoed or mirrored some
of the same ideas in this case here is
it now just all complete conspiracy
imagine
being told that if you don't get
vaccinated you lose access to your child
is that not one of the craziest things
crazy
and people thought i was fear-mongering
sometimes when i said i'm for the
vaccine i'm against the passport even
though i'm vaccinated and people like
why so i'm like i feel like we're going
down a dangerous path and then you see
stories like this and it only reinforces
some of the ideas that you have
so i don't know listen i don't want to
stay too macro with it because i think
it's a complicated discussion and we'll
leave it there but just on a micro level
this is insane
this is insane i don't know how you
could even justify it
what would be the justification
hey man listen honestly i want to just
play this story i'm a big fan of
breaking points i think they run a great
channel and they don't do a great job of
bringing you the news but um god damn
just finding out that the father is now
involved and he's encouraging uh the
order to be reversed so that he can get
full custody of the child like man
custody battles are really dirty oh yeah
people will do whatever it takes whether
it's true or not to win custody of their
child if they one hate the other parent
two want full control like it's just
nasty and of course we don't know the
circumstance between the two parents
whether they're both good or not a lot
of variables are not there but
if it's just that then it's crazy
but like the lady said like the lady
said i said you know this is bananas but
she was wearing yellow i'm shout out to
you uh
i don't know what your name is but likes
was saying if there's other instances
and if there's other uh factors factors
please chime in
because if it's just that whoo according
to the paper it's nice according to
papers he started it he asked are you
vaccinated and it's like listen a lot of
these judges bring their political
biases into these court hearings and
they should and you know what we're not
talking about the stuff with judging
juries i'm talking about judge judges
yeah y'all you be you should be
surprised you better stay on the right
right side of some of these people
because they will throw the book at you
out of spite
out of political leanings and they know
oh they just these judges can be petty
don't you find it strange that there's
even such a thing as conservative or
liberal judges yeah
it's like crazy isn't it
yeah based off their interpretation of
the law and their political leanings
they might apply things i don't know
it's just frightening um but anyways we
wanted to post a story for you guys
let's let us know what you guys think in
the comments below yes that's it so
we're doing good with the views and [ __ ]
now you're gonna put another [ __ ]
vaccine story
[Music]
is
foreign